[Musique]
ce que font les sénateurs ça va ça va
dans le bon sens mais ça s'inscrit de
façon plus large dans le rôle du sénat
qui est de défendre des collectivités
territoriales dans ce cas de leur donner
des moyens
ce milliard d'euros sa frappe aux 20
milliards d'euros est bienvenue mais la
réalité du combat climatique au niveau
territorial est ailleurs elle se situe
dans les plans de même mais sur la
conditionnalité sur l'existence d'un
plan climat de ce rallye ce n'est pas
suffisant c'est l'ambition de ces plans
qu'il faut regarder c'est le manque de
cohérence entre ses plans et d'autres
plantes comme les plans d'urbanisme
c'est vraiment maintenant qu'il faut
agir pour réussir à abaisser ses 140
millions de tonnes chez baissé de 40%
par rapport à 2008 les émissions de co2
ça fait 140 millions de tonnes
la loi dont on parle aujourd'hui les
estimations qu'en effet situe entre 6 et
10 millions de tonnes ce combat gagné
sur 140 pour gagner on est très très
loin du compte
il faut aller plus loin moi je suis
conseiller si peine dans une petite
commune qui fait partie d'une grosse
agglomération qui s'appelle paris saclay
et justement on est sur ce plan climat
depuis à peu près trois mois
on y travaille dans chacune des
collectivités et donc évidemment les
intéressés par ce qui se passe mais on
ne se fait pas beaucoup d'illusions
vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement qui parle
beaucoup l'énergie pas beaucoup et donc
la proposition des sénateurs
républicains en majorité si j'ai bien
compris va dans le bon sens après est-ce
que ce se propose d fait d'acteurs
sera-t-il retenu par l'assemblée des
animaux et par l'engagement donc on en
doute un peu mais ça fait des mois on
parle pensons citoyenne qui débouche sur
pas grand chose par rapport à près de
150 propositions donc on est très
dubitatif
[Musique]
effectivement et on est à quelques jours
des élections départementales gênant
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui la question
des sénateurs république et en
particulier celle de l'élite le suivant
- des moyens aux collectivités
territoriales je pense que les sénateurs
essaye de donner des moyens aux
collectivités locales voire territoriale
entre la région et département il ya
beaucoup de sujets qui dépendent des
collectivités locales et on est souvent
que le volet collectivités locales hors
norme ils sont organisés il faut créer
des logements et en temps il faut
préserver les bois les forêts les terres
agricoles les forcément à un moment on
se retrouve en contradiction je pense
effectivement l'écologie politique a
bien saisi cet aspect là qui font
prendre les aspects de la vie des gens
de façon plus large le bien-être des
gendres aujourd'hui et tout a été fait
politiquement pour que les métropoles
soit attractif c'est le résultat de 2 60
70 ans d'évolution toutes les métropoles
c'est vrai la métropole parisienne mais
c'est vrai des métropoles régionales l
on était attractif drainant beaucoup de
gens des régions agricoles qui sont
autour
et aujourd'hui on est dans des tentes
des déséquilibrés territoire énorme
plus on va mettre deux jambes plusieurs
de concentration ces problèmes
pourraient être importants donc c'est
plutôt à stopper ce développement en
permettre aux gens de changer les
éléments qui font leur vie passer moins
de temps dans les transports
c'est ça aussi la qualité vite la
qualité de vie n'est pas dans un
consumérisme absolue on a bien vu cette
fois également discuté des aspects sur
la publicité et un blocage absolu offert
quoi que ce soit sérieux au frais et à
unifier qui donne qui nous met dans le
cerveau des imaginaires où le bonheur et
le bien-être et à la consommation non
aujourd'hui et demain le bien-être
ce n'est pas la consommation si le temps
de qualité que l'on aura ces échanges
qui sont importants
l'ordre est vendeur de l'effort à faire
pour la transition écologique c'est
l'heure de 5 milliards donc 100
milliards c'est 2000 euros ces deux
mille euros par personne donc vous êtes
en train de faire du saupoudrage un des
éléments qui est qui est important et je
pense que autant que le rôle des avenues
du parlement ça va jouer un rôle
on attend la décision du conseil d'état
suite aux conclusions du rapporteur qui
est très critique
et aujourd'hui c'est pas les
associations écolos et chevalet comme le
gouvernement aime aller à les décrire
qui porte ce constat là c'est le
conseiller pour le climat
c'est le conseil d'état c'est pas le
profil c'est pas le profil écolo donc le
problème est vraiment là dessus je pense
soit courte requête des dizaines et des
minéraux comme le proposait je pense
juste milieu nous les difficultés sur
cette région
c'est le les modes de déplacement les
circulations douces des transports mais
on se trouve toujours dans les îles n
ous et d'à côté la démission ou
l'interdiction
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut des moyens et
les moyens sont donnés aujourd'hui
vêtements région moi je pense qu'il
avait lieu à les collectivités locales
et territoriales et c'est pour ça que
les sénateurs ont un rôle important mais
présentement je me fais pas beaucoup
d'illusions
lorsque les puits d'eau où depuis
quelques années on pas beaucoup de ces
questions et tout le monde en parle mais
par contre il se passe pas grand chose
mais on est toujours optimiste néanmoins